hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from the alindoris abbey
blitz tournament it's arjun hergaisi
versus fabiano caruana and i was
thinking about having a rest today today
you know
we've had a lot going on um
in the chess world but you guys have
been requesting this game so much i
decided i will not be having a rest day
uh and the game definitely deserves to
be shown but not only that uh arjuna
gaisi here uh one uh started by winning
nine games in a row so that's uh
incredible then he had one draw and now
he's facing fabiano corona it's a truly
remarkable game uh so without further
ado let's check it out and then we're
gonna discuss it a little bit more uh
and also yes this is lindoris abby blitz
tournament but it's sort of like uh a
mini tall memorial because tomorrow is
uh tall's uh 85th
anniversary and uh if you guys maybe
want to you know write happy birthday
tal in the comments you know i'm totally
cool with that so that being said let's
check it out ergo ac opens with knight
to f3 he goes for the already opening we
have d5 by fabi d4 and now knight to f6
we have c4 and e6 uh the queen's gambit
declined is on the board and now g3
going for the catalan opening bishop to
be for check by fabi bishop to d2
blocking and now bishop back to d6 so
this is a blitz game we're not going to
dwell too much on uh the the opening
choice knights to c3 and now c6 so this
has all been played before nothing out
of the ordinary here queen to c2 uh
gaining more control over that e4 square
so we want to push e4 next we have
castles and now e4 and here we have a
nice trade in the center knight count
upon captures knight characters knight
captures and queen captures and now uh
black is uh very safely castle the white
king is still in the center of the board
so we want to start by opening the
center and that's what black does he
pushes c5
and now uh this uh it's interesting that
ergasi already had this position in 2019
uh but uh he played bishop to g2 here
his game ended in a draw but now he goes
for bishop to c3 and this is the
engine's top recommendation so
he he obviously went through that game
and he found an improvement so of course
now the bishop is on this diagonal and
it's going to be a great attacking piece
uh and there is a game where knight to
c6 was played but here fabi goes for c
captures on d4 uh sorry c captures on d4
is a known move but fabio goes for
knights to c6 and it is now as of movie
11 that we have a completely new game so
here uh ergasi castle's queen side and
now what do you play here well there's a
lot of action here on the d file he
starts by moving his queen queen to e7
now you don't have to worry about the d
file opening up and bishop to g2 and
here we have bishop to d7 seems like a
normal developing move but it's actually
the beginning of
of bobby's downfall so the idea is that
we want to bring the bishop to d7 maybe
do some trades on d4 and then bring our
bishop to c6 and we're going to be very
happy with this as we're going to
counter white strong light square bishop
and g2 but fabi played bishop to d7 here
and this loses the game on the spot
incredible as it is uh it's not like uh
it loses and then the game is
immediately over but it uh white now has
the opportunity to begin a brilliant
attack so feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out how can white
do this while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh if you found this
you are born to attack you know at all
times and if you just want to enjoy the
show it is of course the captures on c5
we open up this diagonal with tempo but
not only that we don't really care what
black plays on the next move so
obviously black can move the bishop or
black in capturing c5 but whatever black
plays our next move remains the same
unless it's something like bishop to f4
check then of course we have to react to
check but we're not going to discuss
stuff like that so here bishop captures
and c5 was played and now rook captures
on d7 that's the move you had to see and
uh it is all with the idea of freeing up
the g5 square for our knight here so now
you have to capture otherwise you're
just you know down material so queen
captures on d7 and not knight to g5
threatening checkmate on h7 so you have
to block this somehow uh you could play
something like f5 but then we capture on
e6 with check which is not very
impressive uh and also you could play g6
fabi decided to play g6 uh in the now
comes not queen to h4 because if queen
to h4 we can simply block with h5 but
white continues
the attack in the absolute most precise
way and that is knight captures on h7 of
course uh with this uh diagonal
belonging to the bishop the knight
cannot be captured if you capture it
just queen h for checking g8 and queen
to h8 will be checkmate so fabi has to
figure out how to uh go about this
knight captures on h7 so he plays f5
attacks the white queen but now knight
captures an f8 now you pick up the rook
and if the queen is captured then you
capture the black queen on d7 the black
queen is undefended so bishop captures
an f8 and now we have queen back to e2
and now it's not all that big of a deal
uh fob is only down one pawn but his
king side is completely shattered and
white still has this amazing bishop pair
so uh how do you continue here knight to
d4 attacks the white queen and now uh it
seems like you know you really want to
keep this bishop here but just capturing
the knight is also uh
also a move you could also play queen to
e3 just put more pressure then let's say
rook to the eighth and then the game
continues but it's a blitz game you
can't just you know uh
figure stuff out forever so bishop
captures on d4 was played queen captures
and rook to d1 we use this uh tempo to
get the rook into the game queen to f6
we need to guard our e6 pawn and now
bishop captures on b7 it seems like a
very risky move because black could also
very easily mount an attack against the
white king the rook is of course coming
to b8 but white uh again plays
everything with surgical precision even
for a blitz game rook to d7 now guarding
the bishop and gaining very nice control
of the seventh rank so here bishop to g7
now fabi also has a very nice attacking
setup but uh with the bishop blocking
the rook and with the queen guarding the
b2 pawn so far black can't really do
anything about this but what can white
to do well you do have past c pawn so
you're just gonna push it so he starts
by pushing it c5 now c6 and c7 if black
is not ready to meet this it's a game
over
and you could try something like rook to
d8 that's one way to do it but even with
this move that's considered the best
just captures captures and queen
captures on e6 they're still the past c
pawn i mean there's there's there's no
way you can play this so fabi tried to
king to h8 now at least uh some like
queen captures on e6 will not come with
check and maybe you will have time to
check maybe the black king
but now just c6 and how can black
go about this he plays a queen to f8 and
now we have a3 making some breeding room
for the king but also
uh
it wasn't really necessary because if
you just push c7 it's still winning
we're gonna capture on b7 and now okay
you have to you know maybe worry about
this but not really just queen c4 and
that's it we we we win the game uh rook
the rook here does not work because we
simply capture the c7 pawn with check so
here uh just uh rook captures on b7 and
queen to c4 is winning one little check
we really don't care king d1 and next
move we win the game so instead uh okay
a3 was played like i said it's a blitz
game queen to c5 would check now king to
b1 and king the h7 now getting the king
away from the back ring but now queen c2
and black really can't afford to trade
queens here if you trade queens just c7
c8 and that's it so after queen to c2
queen to b5 was played uh still you know
putting a lot of pressure on this b2
pawn but now just c7 attacking the rook
rook captures on b7 and now how do you
finish this game with white well you
don't want to bring a queen into early
in the game if you just play c8 queen
then we pick up the rook on d7 and yes
you have two queens but it's a queen
rook and bishop and there's a lot of
pressure here white is still better but
you know it would be it would be pretty
crazy so what can white do well we
simply eliminate uh the the bishop here
and get rid of our target on d7 so rook
captures on d7 was g7 was played and he
was in this position animal 30 that
fabiano corona resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
incredible incredible run by uh arjun
ergaise in the start of this lindoris
abbey uh blitz tournament so winning
nine games in a row then a draw against
matarosian and then another brilliant
win against fabi fabi retaliated uh in
the next round immediately of course uh
after this they played again then fabi
won and in the end they had the exact
same number of points but neither of
them won the tournament we're gonna
discuss this in a different video uh
this one is just uh enjoyed the beauty
of this game so here you resign because
after you deal with this checking
captures on g7 just c8 queen and now the
queen and rook of course are helpless
against the two queens and we've
actually reached the position from the
thumbnail
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh now i'm very very glad i
did not take a risk today as you know
this a game like this definitely
deserves to be shown
i would like to thank sas and faiz
alessandra atura tom darrolla micah
kennedy and the david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
everything else that's happening in the
chess world and of course on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day